Many of the differences between JavaScript and Python
are similar to the differences between American English and British English.
Sometimes the spelling changes a bit, or the pronunciation changes a bit,
but in general, they are mutually intelligible.
It should look very similar, but with 1 or 2 extra letters.
JavaScript is big on curly braces.
Python is big on tabbing.
JavaScript is big on semi-colons.
Python not so much.
JavaScript really loves parentheses.
Python could take them or leave them.
Python could have these, could have these, but doesn't have to.
They're somewhat optional.
And in some sense, preferring one over the other is a bit like preferring
Brutus to Caesar.
I've heard that Brutus is an honorable man, or at least so Mark Antony told me.
They're both entirely reasonable from our perspective.
Is this a dagger I see before me?
I guess this one must be Brutus, and this one must be Caesar,
and you know which one is which because of these convenient labels.
Here I've written a new JavaScript function
called "ironcrutchli."
This one is not recursive, but it takes a formal argument x
and then does some reasoning based on x and returns values as a result.
I want to make sure that you're following along with JavaScript,
so I'm going to have you tell me what this function evaluates to
based on a few different inputs.
In this fill-in-the-blank quiz, for each one of these inputs,
imagine we're calling ironcrutchli on 0,
so this 0 is bound to the value of x.
What would the output be, similarly for 1, 2, and 9?